[Música]
continúa el caos en Estados Unidos a
causa de la tormenta helada Elliot más
de 7000 vuelos fueron cancelados entre
lunes y martes en Nueva York que el
estado más afectado Secreto del estado
de emergencia para facilitar la entrega
de ayuda Federal
la justicia estadounidense ordenó al
gobierno mantener vigente el título 42
la Norma que permite expulsar migrantes
de la frontera de forma inmediata por
motivos sanitarios el presidente Joe
biden Indicó que es probable que la
corte se tome hasta junio para
determinar cuándo se levantará la medida
ahora los mexicanos tendrán 12 días de
vacaciones continuos a partir del primer
año de haber sido empleados esto gracias
a un decreto firmado por el presidente
Andrés Manuel López Obrador
anteriormente solo gozaban de cinco días
de descanso
Bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos damos inicio en
Estados Unidos donde continúan los
estragos de la tormenta helada Elliot
más de 7000 vuelos fueron cancelados en
las últimas 48 horas dejando a miles de
viajeros varados en aeropuertos del país
esto al tiempo que continuaron las
Nevadas y vientos huracanados
acompañados de bajas temperaturas el
estado de Nueva York fue declarado en
emergencia para facilitar la entrega de
ayudas federales Andrés triviño nos
amplía los detalles
finaliza la tormenta gélida más fuerte
de los últimos 40 años los
estadounidenses empiezan a recuperarse
de los estragos de la tormenta Elliot
con un saldo de medio centenar de
Muertos un millón 700 de hogares a
oscuras y caos en el transporte en
Navidad la mayoría de Los afectados
están en Búfalo estado en Nueva York
tras registrar hasta 128 centímetros de
nieve las condiciones de la tormenta por
supuesto se han ido pero vamos a
responder de alguna manera durante
varios días mientras continúan abriendo
la ciudad quiero agradecerles a todos
por el trabajo que han hecho
el este y el sur del país experimentaron
Este martes una subida de temperaturas
mientras que otro frente frío llegó a la
costa oeste con nieve y lluvias los
destrozos de la tormenta afectan los
planes de fin de año de miles de
personas luego de que más de 12.000
vuelos fueran cancelados desde el jueves
pasado la más afectada es la aerolínea
South tras reportar fallos en el
software de programación de horarios
me acaban de decir que está cancelado y
no saldrá nada Durante los próximos tres
o cuatro días Así que tomaré un barco
llegamos el día de Navidad y el vuelo
Fue cancelado a último minuto por lo
cual tuvimos que modificar todos
nuestros planes de viaje la gobernadora
de Nueva York que informó que varias
carreteras en la zona más afectada
fueron reabiertas así como los cruces
fronterizos con Canadá por su parte el
Gobierno Federal ordenó coordinar las
acciones que sean necesarias para
retomar la normalidad
continuamos con otra noticia Que centra
la atención de los estadounidenses la
justicia decidió que se mantenga el
título 42 la medida que permite expulsar
a migrantes por motivos sanitarios el
presidente Joe biden Indicó que es
probable que la Corte Suprema se tome
hasta junio para determinar el futuro de
la normativa en principio la medida iba
a ser levantada el 21 de diciembre pero
la justicia la mantuvo en vigor tal como
lo hace en esta ocasión lo que deja en
el Limbo a miles de migrantes que han
llegado hasta la frontera sur del país y
esperan en medio de Las heladas
temperaturas que les permitan Ingresar a
territorio estadounidense
continuando con temas migratorios vamos
a Nicaragua donde continúa El Éxodo
ciudadano miles de personas buscan
llegar a Estados Unidos atravesando
Centroamérica en su camino los migrantes
denuncian las irregularidades a las que
se ven sometidos en países como Honduras
unas que deben sortear si pretenden
seguir con su deseo de alcanzar el norte
del continente el informe es de Manuela
Cano
un bus repleto de razones para migrar
estos nicaragüenses dejan su país
buscando alcanzar Estados Unidos en el
camino sin embargo se encuentran con un
gran primer obstáculo la corrupción de
las autoridades hondureñas Todo es
dinero Todo es dinero te ponen pero te
dicen que por una letra o por un número
o un documento no está bien y que no
pasas tal como Jessica Centeno muchos
nicaragüenses denuncian que los puestos
de migración en Honduras pueden llegar a
cobrarles desde 40 a 250 dólares debido
a supuestas irregularidades en sus
papeles un monto que deben pagar si
pretenden seguir con su periplo hasta
Estados Unidos es un viaje que no se
tiene descanso como madre porque toca
luchar más de lo normal que una madre
lucha por sus hijos
y si se corre mucho riesgo la pobreza y
la represión por parte del gobierno
Daniel Ortega son algunos de los motivos
compartidos por los cuales los
nicaragüenses siguen optando por migrar
por las Crisis que hay en Nicaragua
estamos sin trabajo y las cosas están la
canasta básica pues no tenemos Con qué
comprarla no hay facilidad ahora con
todo caro y sin trabajo entonces por eso
es el viaje Después que hacemos para ver
si buscamos una mejor vida más de
100.000 nicaragüenses migraron de forma
irregular a Estados Unidos entre enero y
agosto de este año según la oficina de
aduanas y protección fronteriza de dicho
país en múltiples ocasiones Ortega ha
asegurado que El Éxodo responde a las
sanciones estadounidenses que han
afectado la situación de la nación
centroamericana en Perú familiares de
las personas que fallecieron durante las
recientes protestas contra el gobierno
nacional señalan a los militares como
culpables de las muertes de sus seres
queridos recordemos que el gobierno de
la presidenta Dina boluarte declaró el
estado de de emergencia y restringió
algunos derechos civiles al tiempo que
permitió que el ejército mantuviera el
control público en varias localidades
familias que exigen una respuesta el
cese temporal de violencia en Perú no
diezma el dolor y los reclamos de los
peruanos que perdieron seres queridos En
el contexto de las protestas para la
hermana de una de las víctimas mortales
el culpable está claro prácticamente él
ha sido asesinado por parte de los
militares o de parte de los militares y
la verdad para nosotros esto es un
un cruel ataque que hicieron contra mi
hermano no entre los familiares de las
personas fallecidas existe un factor
común se supone que para defender
territorio o quizás enfrentarse pero
también con otras militares en la selva
quizás pero no salir acá a la ciudad en
medio donde están niños adultos personas
mayores y hacer sus disparos como lo han
hecho y Es que luego de la detención del
expresidente Pedro Castillo las
protestas en varias regiones de la
nación hicieron que la presidenta
boluarte declarará el estado de
emergencia una condición Que restringió
derechos cívicos y permitió que el
ejército ayudara en las labores de
control público
comunico que he dado las instrucciones
para que se recupere pacíficamente el
control del orden interno sin afectar
los derechos fundamentales de la
ciudadanía
a pesar de ser pacíficos en su mayoría
los enfrentamientos entre manifestantes
y la policía dejaron 22 muertos entre
ellos un joven de 15 años Mientras tanto
los problemas institucionales continúan
en la víspera fueron arrestados seis
generales Implicados En el caso de
ascensos irregulares mediante sobornos
durante la gestión de castillo
el presidente de México Andrés Manuel
López Obrador firmó el decreto que
oficializa la ampliación de las
vacaciones que ahora serán de doce días
continuos a partir del primer año de
empleo anteriormente solo gozaban de
cinco días de descanso Mario carbonel
corresponsal de Francia veinticuatro nos
cuenta más desde Ciudad de México
desde el 1 de enero de 2023 todos los
trabajadores del sector formal en México
gozarán de 12 días de vacaciones al
cumplir el primer año de trabajo Esto
fue posible gracias a una modificación a
dos artículos de la Ley Federal del
Trabajo que así lo establecen y precisan
que se añadirán dos días de vacaciones
por cada año subsecuente laboral así
hasta llegar a 20 días y a partir del
sexto año de trabajo Se añadirán dos
días de vacaciones por cada cinco años
de servicio esta iniciativa fue una
propuesta original del partido
movimiento ciudadano y que después fue
enriquecida por los partidos del trabajo
y el partido Morena si bien fue aprobado
desde el 3 de noviembre en el senado en
la cámara de diputados pretendieron
modificarla para que no necesariamente
tuvieran que disfrutarse los 12 días de
manera continua el senado sin embargo
advirtió que no aceptaría estos cambios
por lo que a final de cuentas quedó
aprobado como originalmente estaba
planteado el presidente López Obrador
dijo que ya firmó el decreto por lo que
entrará en vigor conforme a lo
establecido esta iniciativa pretende
apegarse a lo sugerido por la
organización internacional de trabajo
que pretende que sea un piso mínimo de
18 días si bien Aún está lejos con estos
12 días representa un avance pues
durante 50 años no hubo modificaciones a
la ley y los trabajadores únicamente
gozaban de seis días de vacaciones al
contar con su primer año de trabajo
López Obrador también dijo que es
necesario un periodo suficiente de
descanso y que además esto redundará en
una mayor productividad para las
empresas
fin del informativo volvemos en breve
[Música]